so let's so you're having a hearing in
two weeks yep let's uh let's let's go to
the uh we'll we'll hear about that oh
yeah we'll get the update but I want to
use this opportunity to talk about you
know like I think we're getting into the
territory where everything's going
absolutely insane and so we have this
tweet here which exemplifies it and
makes me very happy
Rachel Bay says the officials who
represent Maryland's three westernmost
counties in the general assembly have
asked if their counties can join West
Virginia yes yes so a lot of people
don't know this West Virginia and
Virginia were one state
then the Civil War happened and West
Virginia and Virginia went bye-bye West
Virginia said we think slavery is bad
we're with the north we want to stay in
the union Virginia said we're going to
be the capital of the Confederacy right
now we're starting to see it's getting
so bad politically especially with the
story you're telling about the FDA and
and the risks we have the censorship the
media
we operate right now this studio is in
one of these counties I am very excited
to hear that this is happening we have
these two letters first
this is from speaker Roger hanshaw and
president Craig Blair it says speaker
hanche on President Blair Arts to them
sorry
we the undersigned state representatives
for Garrett and Allegheny counties in
the state of Maryland request that you
consider adding us as constituent
counties to the state of West Virginia
we believe this Arrangement may be
mutually beneficial for both States and
for our local constituencies please
advise on next steps and then I love
this one speaker Hench on President
Blair we the undersigned state
representatives for Washington county in
the state of Maryland also request you
consider adding Washington County as a
constituent County to the state of West
Virginia we believe it's a Arrangement
may be mutually beneficial for both
States and for our local constituencies
please advise on next steps I live in
West Virginia because it's a Tri-State
you know we shop sometimes in Virginia
we go for dinner I live in in West
Virginia but we work in Maryland so
we're just between all three
um uh delegate Mike McKay and delegate
William wivell
we are here as your our eager
constituents wanting to help in any way
possible to allow us to join with West
Virginia
look so West Virginia I live there I'm a
resident I have constitutional carry
it's fantastic it's way better
Maryland is Western Maryland where we
are it's effectively West Virginia if
you ask anybody around here there's a
guy who lives over here he's got these
massive signs that say like swap 40
miles that way because bring your boots
amazing sign by the way and uh the
people here would love it to not be
under the boot of Baltimore oh yeah
culturally socially economically
politically I mean they're right in the
middle of the place that triggered the
last Civil War
John Brown so the uh so it makes sense
and what has to happen is the Maryland
Wisconsin I'm sorry West Virginia
Maryland legislatures have to approve
and then Congress has to approve never
gonna happen probably not but maybe
because if you're Maryland do you really
want Western Maryland if you're the
Democrats in Baltimore you probably
would love to jettison them yeah West
Virginia why not add your territory add
some tax base you'll get a Democrat
Governor every every time if you get rid
of Western the only thing is probably
they would look at congressional
representation would it give West
Virginia enough to add back their third
seat that they lost yeah hypothetically
this ever happens what's the time frame
how long would that oh it can happen
quickly ml it requires both legislators
and Congress it can happen with I mean
the old days they used to approve States
within weeks within months
so what do we what do we what do we have
to do to encourage this that's a good
question I mean the I mean I wouldn't
encourage anything you know that uh uh
too provocative well look this is this
is just people saying
we don't get we know we're not like the
people of DC in Baltimore we're more
like West Virginia so we'll just
convince the people in DC and Baltimore
that uh Western Maryland is really
holding them back and they just need to
jettison them and give them to West
Virginia it's a good point you don't
want to have these maggots you know
voting in your elections Maryland's got
a republican Governor exactly it would
be a Democratic governor if they would
just let these counties go that's right
but I don't think they would it's a lot
like what's happening in Oregon you know
the Eastern Oregon counties are also uh
oh they want that they voted right they
voted to Eastern Washington once out
they would like to join greater Idaho
make Idaho like a true Idaho you know
it's funny having grown up my whole life
in a city and then lived in New York and
then ultimately just being like it's
better to not live in these cities
because they're insane yeah it is funny
I drove through New York to get here had
coffee with my best friend in New York
and it was the I know my frame of the
world has changed with what's happened
in the last two years but it was the
first time I really appreciated I forget
who said it that living in a big city is
like prisoners sort of um learning to
love their imprisonment and you know
we're in New York I see people in the
park playing violin and I see people
everyone's talking everyone's trying to
make the best of life in New York but it
was the first time that I really felt
like the city was too much it looked
like people were just trying to make the
best of their living but that people
didn't really love it anymore but that
might have been a lot of projection
coming from me
did you stop in New York City yeah New
York City Property it was in the Lower
East Side did you need to present your
papers to get that coffee I did not I
didn't because we drank it outside
um everybody and I said on my channel
I'm I'm I got both shots everyone knows
because I've crossed the border but I I
refuse I mean except for bowling with my
kids where's the camera that I have to
apologize to again except for bowling
with my kids that one day I I refuse to
do it but I don't need that anymore do
you have like a card like no I have a
picture of my paper uh literally the
funny thing is after I got my second
shot I took a picture of the paper they
printed out the pharmacy sent it to my
wife with a very funny joke like haha
the papers when they ask yeah and it
became it became a very funny email that
I sent to my wife because they literally
when we were traveling New Brunswick
they like show me your papers I had only
had one shot at the time I was like man
they're gonna they're gonna tell me I
can't go on a family vacation now that's
ridiculous
this is the crazy thing to me I mean and
that would work in New York City it's
working it's work everybody every sign
said you want to sit down indoors
vaccine mean I mean the fact that you've
got a picture of a piece of paper and
that's like okay so what's stopping
people from you know oh there's massive
already I have had I mean I will never
do it because I don't trust it not to
get hacked in terms of like disclose to
the authorities but this people I know
people who are who are providing
personally I know nobody I have no idea
I know nobody but uh like I said but
there's a high probability that there
are a lot of these people and that's why
these numbers of how many people
actually took this or have this should
be questioned I don't represent them so
you know just what what if someone like
went to Mexico and then just went to a
doctor well that's the key is that you
get International that's what they can't
control that's where there's no U.S
tracking for that's why ultimately the
goal is to have international tracking
you know have a little chip in your body
that everybody can be Universal I
already got a chip in your passport the
world economic Forum called for a global
passport system of of medical records
that keep you up to date with your
status and your tests that will be uh
used with uh you know internationally
with all the countries being synced into
the same system that's literally what
they were just talking about months ago
so yeah this has been okay for a very
long part of your financial system
that's what they're talking about fed
coin that's going to be part of your
identification yeah the bank of England
the bank of England is literally talking
about building a cryptocurrency that's
centralized controlled by them just
after a few days ago one of their
spokespersons said that Bitcoin is going
to destroy the financial markets as
calling for their own Bitcoin that's
that's fedcoin controlled by them at
everything imagine the control they
could cut off your ability to buy gas
buy food do anything and that's
literally their plan that's the social
credit score it's already exists in
China and there's plans to implement it
here in the United States through the
vaccine mandate through the vaccine
passports it's a social credit score uh
in a trojan horse they'll experiment on
Canada first well and I just don't
understand the the rationale behind the
vaccine passport you can go in order
your coffee then leave but you can't sit
down in there to drink your coffee as if
and as if the double vaccination is the
criteria that's the most relevant and
not if you're worried about transmission
a negative test but it's it's nuts uh
but people are putting up with it in
Canada in New York there's a little more
Defiance so so I can explain it it's
actually quite simple
um but so if if you walk into a
restaurant you need to wear your mask
because for people uh you know walking
around the kova is at head level but
when you sit down now you can take your
mask off and it's okay now however
if you're not vaccinated actually
inverts you're okay standing up walking
in but sitting down is when you get
problems no no not anymore they changed
that rule you have to even if you're
vaccinated still wear the masks and in
Australia this virus usually goes to
sleep at around 8 PM when the government
says that there's a curfew so this is
and also very strangely it's also it's
also a super spreader event when it's
when it comes to Republican protest but
it's it's something that heals people
during leftist black lives matter
protest at 8pm is when it's most active
that's why everyone has to stay home
yeah unless you're dealing then you
don't even have to wear the mask and you
go into a high-end restaurant well
everybody knows that Joe Biden is is the
healthiest president you've ever had
exactly exactly very much that is a
fiddle yeah yes I'll one up the insanity
did I did I talk about the isolating
kids in Canada no because yeah we got an
email from school I did a video on this
because I didn't believe it was true
where out of Ontario they were saying if
a kid came in contact with someone who
tested positive that kid has to isolate
and then you saw people tweeting online
my kids crying in the bedroom I'm
slipping food under the door oh I saw
that okay and now I don't know if I
believe those tweets because you have to
be a little skeptical but then we in our
community got a recommendation
kids and eight-year-old kids in a class
came in contact with the keto tested
positive all kids were asymptomatic if
they were even infected but they tested
negative no symptoms negative tests had
to isolate for 10 days and I expressed
some discontent um with the government
policy say this is idiotic and then a
total coincidence the next day they the
government issues a correction no longer
need to isolate an eight-year-old kid
who's tested negative with no symptoms
it's it is I don't know what they're
doing like there's that guy awakened
with JP who puts out some good videos
this is what we do today throw something
on the wall that's gonna be the criteria
with all these vaccine mandates all of
them are about asymptomatic risk I mean
there is no real risk the only risk the
only limitation of vaccine mandate
lawsuits they should expand upon is
asymptomatic risk is not a meaningful
risk of spread and that's the only thing
the vaccine purports to solve and it
doesn't solve its own admission
allegedly again and all the data should
be questioned because all the data is
coming from Pfizer and Pfizer has been
cut fudging the data fudging the trials
taking people out of trials that gets
sick from the vaccine like that 12 year
old that ended up in a wheelchair and
then she was a part of the trial group
and when the trial group or the report
came out she wasn't a part of it I can't
go into details but there'll be a big
whistleblower coming out on that precise
yeah it's crazy what's happening we got
to be careful with anecdotes yeah
absolutely as far as oh no I represent a
whistleblower we'll be no that's
different I just mean like you know
um my my concern is you know someone
will see a story and they'll say this
proves my view of the situation and I'm
like there's tons of that of course
causation correlation anecdotes proved
nothing except that you have you have an
example but um I just love the fact that
everybody now trusts Pfizer who paid a
2.3 billion 2.3 billion they trust Merc
who paid however much for their foreign
in Canada the government just apologized
for its horrible treatment of the
indigenous with its residential schools
we did it for their own good at the time
or we said we did yes we you know we
knew they were dying we hit it now we
apologize for it trust us today did you
guys hear this Johnson Johnson thing
apparent I think it's the talcum powder
right they are they're separating it off
into a they're spitting off a new
company and then bankrupting it so they
don't got to pay a settlement exactly
it's it's hilarious to see that in
leftist subreddits where they're like
evil Corporation but then also like haha
magas are dumb for not getting
vaccinated yes it's atrocious completely
and in the cases that they're citing in
the cases that were used for eugenics in
the in the 19th and 20th Century so it's
very dangerous what's happening legally
politically across the board uh people
you know I wanna I wanna stress this
point too because people often say when
we had Michael Schellenberg for instance
he's like what what what what about
people say we've had other mandates like
MMR and stuff and I'm like I've never
been required to get a vaccine to go to
7-Eleven before exactly not only that
there's always been religious
accommodations for all those children
child vaccines there's always been
medical accommodations there's always
been prior immunity accommodations so
we've never had to end again those as
you know we're limited to kids for
public education for which you could opt
out so it's a completely unanalogous
comparison that a lot of these people
are using the virus itself is not
analogous either because
umbrella actually posed meaningful risk
for kids this we're talking now in
Canada compelled vaccination of five to
eleven-year-olds for in Canada 300 000
some odd cases 1500 hospitalizations 15
deaths and we just found out two weeks
ago at the very least on this occasion a
death day reported in a 14 year old
attributed to kovid the sister came out
and said the kid had a stage four brain
cancer was hospitalized in a coma and
they did a test on the kid but the
there's two words here vaccine mandate
and the most important is mandate like
University of Denver saying flu vaccines
this is I think just a the bigger issue
I think is they want to get people to
mandate they want to get to the point
where you have the app where they can
start mandating many many more things
than just vaccination they can mandate
any kind of medical problems right the
whole goal was to establish the state's
power and the corporate power over the
human body that they control you you
don't control yourself once they
establish that legal precedent we know
where it leads because they gave us four
sterilization and forced attention camps
based on Ancestry and then ultimately
the Nazis and there was a lot of really
messed up stuff happening in the early
1900s oh yeah and that's what and when
they cite those cases I'm like do you
recognize you're citing the same Supreme
Court that said racial segregation was a
good idea well to be to be fair though
Derek Bell agreed with Plessy versus
Ferguson and uh he's like a hero to the
wokusts so yeah I mean the levels of
insanity I mean it's the professional
class has too much power that's the
problem thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday right
at 8 pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time